all right hello my name is Mikhail
Shapiro I'm a professor of chemical
engineering at Caltech and it's my
pleasure to talk to you today about how
we can use ultrasound to modulate neural
activity before I dive into that I
wanted to give you a quick introduction
to our lab in general we are interested
in developing technologies to image and
control the function of cells deep
inside the body this is motivated first
of all by basic biology because whether
we're talking about neurons in our
brains or microbes in our guts or immune
cells and tumor cells fighting each
other somewhere else in our body to
really understand how that biology works
we want to study it within the context
of the intact organism and in this case
we're talking about the brain and in
addition we're interested in developing
cell based diagnostic and therapeutic
agents that can migrate into the body
and can help us diagnose and treat
disease and there have been spectacular
examples of that recently with
engineered immune cells for Carty
immunotherapy or engineered probiotics
for the microbiome and potentially cells
that would help with neuro degeneration
and we believe that in those cases it's
going to be important to image and
control the function of these very
sophisticated agents that we're
introducing into the body to see where
are they are they alive are they
functional are they executing the
programs that we put into them
and today imaging and controlling the
function of cells inside the body is
challenging because most of our best
techniques for visualizing and
controlling cellular function use light
and these are things like optogenetics
and fluorescent proteins which derive a
lot of their power from the fact that
they're genetically incredible and can
therefore connect very intimately to
what's happening inside of cells of
course the limitation of light is that
it's very difficult to get a deep into
tissues usually it gets scattered within
about a millimeter and so it's tough to
scale these technologies up to a whole
brain level especially as we're talking
about mammals and larger and larger
organisms at the same time there are
technologies like ultrasound
magnetic residents that use penetrant
forms of energy by which I mean that
sound waves and magnetic fields by and
large have no problem getting in and out
of our bodies but for the most part
these technologies have not yet been
connected as well to what's happening at
the molecular and cellular level and so
the big picture of what we try to do in
my lab is to take these technologies in
these forms of energy and connect them
to the cellular level through
biomolecular engineering meaning that we
find we engineer we evolve proteins or
other genetically incredible materials
that can interact with sound waves or
magnetic fields and the research in our
lab quite literally breaks down into
sound waves and magnetic fields and
engineering various kinds of molecules
or devices or biophysical methods to
couple these forms of energy to allow us
to image and control the function of
cells and in this talk I'm gonna only
focus on the bottom left quadrant of
this slide and talk about that within
the context of neuroscience how can we
use ultrasound to modulate the activity
of the brain now the reason we and
others are so interested in using
ultrasound for this purpose is that it's
the only form of non ionizing energy
that can be focused at depth within
large tissue like the brain and this
actually works not just in animal models
but in human patients and focused
ultrasound can be applied non-invasively
through the intact skull and have a
spatial precision on the order of a
couple millimeters within humans and
even finer in smaller organisms and at
that focal spot it can be used to
deliver mechanical or thermal effects
and clinically today this is used for
ablation where you deliver enough energy
that you fry a local spot of tissue and
for example can use that to treat
essential tremor by ablating the
subthalamic nucleus and this is an
fda-approved procedure in the United
States now of course
in our case we don't want to fry the
brain tissue we want to modulate it so
we want to apply ultrasound and turn on
or off neural circuits and I'm going to
talk about two ways to do that one is
based on direct ultrasonic
neuromodulation and the other one is
based on using ultrasound to open the
blood-brain barrier and enable us to
locally control things with chemo
genetics so in the first topic this is
really something that was recently
brought into the scientific sphere
through the work of Jamie Tyler and
colleagues who showed that you can just
apply low intensity low frequency
ultrasound to the brain in mice and
later on in humans and elicit neural
responses and this was surprising but
also exciting because you're not
modifying the animals in any way in this
case there's no genetic modifications no
chemical modifications you're just
pointing the ultrasound and you're
seeing responses and a lot of these
responses look like what's shown in this
video if we can activate the video at
this point
and what we see here is a rodent that is
being stimulated with the ultrasound and
when the ultrasound turns on we see this
motor response and this was exciting
because it suggested that ultrasound is
able to directly activate motor circuits
in this case and of course the big
question at that point was how does this
work and I think it's very important to
understand that so we can optimize this
technology figure out its advantages and
limitations and try to apply it
carefully in neuroscience research and
so we embarked on a study of that
question in collaboration with Dora
South also here at Caltech to look at
the mechanisms of ultrasonic modulation
both in vivo and in vitro for the in
vivo case we are using calcium imaging
of the mouse cortex in transgenic mice
while applying the ultrasound and trying
to see what's going on and in vitro
we're working with cultured neurons
where we can again look with imaging at
what the ultrasound is doing to them and
we can have much more access to perturb
them in various ways pharmacologically
genetically etc to try to get at some of
these mechanism I'm going to give you a
summary of what we found in both of
these cases so first of all looking at
cortical activation in mice in response
to ultrasound so what the experiment
we're doing is taking skull fins Mouse
preparations doing wide field gcamp
six calcium imaging and applying
ultrasound to the visual cortex of the
animal this is a mouse that's under
under light anesthesia and we were
hoping we were hoping to see was a
response in the region that we're
targeting with ultrasound but to our
surprise what we found instead is that
there was a lot of activation of the
auditory regions which were not directly
targeted by our ultrasound giel and you
can see that in these images here the
auditory regions are outlined in the top
of the slide and then in the bottom part
of the slide we're looking at that as a
function of intensity and time and the
little circle and the bottom images
outlines where we're applying the
ultrasound and so what you can see there
is you get instead of direct activation
at the Austin focus you were getting
this contralateral biased activation of
the auditory cortex and if you apply a
large enough intensity and wait long
enough yes you will also see activation
of the visual cortex but it wasn't clear
that this this activation was happening
directly or was arising as a byproduct
of auditory cortex activation and so if
you look at this in a little bit more
detail over over multiple animals you
can see consistently that you get
contralateral auditory cortex activation
that is happening to a higher amplitude
and earlier then you get visual cortex
stimulation at the target and there's a
contralateral bias meaning that when
we're stimulating on the right side of
the mouse brain we were getting more
activation in the left auditory cortex
so this made us think that you know
maybe there's some kind of auditory
activation and this was a little bit
surprising because you know ultrasound
by definition is operating in
frequencies that we shouldn't be able to
hear and the frequencies that we're
using here should be inaudible to mice
however perhaps there's some kind of
conversion that's happening or there's
something that kind of frequencies that
are part of our stimulation parameters
that are not just all sound frequencies
but could be audible to these animals
and so to test that we compared the
cortical response to our ultrasound
shown in the middle row there to light
showing above and to sound shown below
and you can see that when we apply
flashes of light this is to the eyes we
see very nice visual cortex activation
but when we apply both ultrasound and
sound we see this pattern of activation
that corresponds to auditory activation
and the fact that the ultrasound
response and the audible sound response
played through speakers on the outside
looks similar suggests that indeed there
is an auditory side effect that is
at play here and we can actually compare
quantitatively the similarity in the
quartet cortical response between the
ultrasound versus sound and light and
show quantitatively that the light hat
looks dissimilar from both of the other
two whereas the ultrasound and sound
look very similar to each other in terms
of the effect on the cortical activation
and that also made us wonder whether
some of the movement responses that are
seen when you apply ultrasound to
animals could be due to these auditory
effects rather than direct stimulation
of the motor cortex and the idea is that
in these lightly an anesthetized animals
there could be a startle response to a
strong sensation and so to test for that
we measured EMG signals in these mice
while applying ultrasound as well as
light sound and an air puff to the front
of the face as a non auditory non visual
stimulus and what we saw is that while
light Andy's anesthetized animals was
not eliciting a mechanical response
audible sound ultrasound and air puff or
eliciting similar responses and that
made us think that perhaps this is a
startle type of reflex now to test
whether the auditory the ultrasound is
producing this kind of startle response
through an auditory effect we tried to
deafen these animals chemically and so
here we're doing administration of
kanamycin and if you're awesome I'd wear
that produces a partial deafening and we
hypothesize that when we do that the
responses to sound would be diminished
if the response to ultrasound is
happening through auditory pathways the
response to ultrasound should also be
diminished but the response to air puffs
should not be affected because that's
not happening through this deafening
susceptible pathway and indeed that
turned out to be the case so when we
look at the deafened animals they had a
reduced response to both sound and
ultrasound but not to air puffs and so
that makes us believe that we that we
have this auditory on a side effect
that's happening in these mice and while
we were doing this study there was a
complimentary study that was happening
at University of Minnesota led by hunks
on grow in Hubert limbs lab that was
published back-to-back with our paper
where they did similar experiments in
guinea pigs and in this case they were
doing electrophysiology recording from
the auditory cortex while applying
ultrasound to various places in the
brain and also not even in the brain for
example on the eye of the animal and
they saw responses that they could
record regardless of where they were
stimulating which also suggested that
there might be a an auditory side effect
happening here and to show that this was
happening through on three mechanisms
they did a very elegant experiment where
they drained the cochlear fluid from the
ear of these animals and showed that the
responses disappeared so that the things
that they were looking at were also
likely to have been these auditory
effects so you know that was kind of a a
you know somewhat depressing
instead of findings for us because we
were hoping that you know just be simple
and direct etc but you know I think in
retrospect there's good reason to think
that this should have been detectable
and that's because the post parameters
that were used in both of these studies
and in fact were used in the majority of
the published work on ultrasonic near
modulation to that date were repetitive
ultrasound stimulation where the
ultrasound is being applied at hundreds
of kilohertz frequency that's inaudible
but the pulses are being repeated at a
repetition frequency of for example a
kilohertz which is in the audible range
and so if you take a Fourier transform
of that waveform then you're gonna see
not just your ultrasound frequency but
also the pulse repetition frequency
which could cause these auditory effects
and even if you are creating a
continuous wave pattern that should be a
pure tone the abrupt
turning on and turning off of that
pattern can also lead to the generation
of additional frequencies besides your
pure tone frequency and so that's
something that we're trying to
investigate to a greater depth as I'll
talk about in a few slides now at the
same time as we were doing this in vivo
investigation and getting these kind of
unwelcome let's say results we're also
doing in vitro experiments and in this
case we're working with cortical neurons
from mice that are cultured on
acoustically transparent substrates and
in 3-dimensional hydrogel culture or
obviously there's no auditory system so
any direct that we should be seeing from
ultrasound so I think that these neurons
should be direct effects and this is
work led by some genu a postdoctoral
fellow in our lab and what we saw here
again using optical imaging to look at
this at these responses were nice robust
responses so we see these calcium
responses both in two-dimensional and
three-dimensional culture that scale as
expected with intensity and post
duration using parameters that match the
upper end of what has been used in in
vivo studies and so this suggests that
there's in addition to any kind of
auditory side effect that there's also a
direct effect that ultrasound can have
on these neurons and we've been studying
the mechanisms by which that is
happening and and what I want to show
here is just a few things that it's not
so it's not pore forming so after
ultrasound stimulation the neurons
continue to be intact so those times not
is not forming pores and it's not a
thermal mechanism we can measure the
temperature changes and they are less
than a tenth of a degree Celsius it is
not a synaptic phenomenon we can block
synapses and continue to see the same
kind of responses and it probably does
not involve cavitation so for this we
have what's shown here are some voltage
recordings where we're seeing the
depolarization and if there were a
cavitation there was a prediction that
there should be hyper-polarization
happening as well
Nishan by looking at ultra-high frame
rate video recordings of these neurons
as they're being exposed to ultrasound
we don't really see any kind of bubbles
so at least there aren't things that are
visible at the micron type of level that
are involved so this really seems to be
some kind of direct mechanical
interaction with with neurons and we're
we're just finishing up a story about
what mechanosensitive receptors are
involved in mediating that interaction
so where we are with this director or
sonic neuromodulation is that there
seems to be an auditory side effect that
is present in addition to whatever kind
of direct effects are there and some of
the motor responses that we and others
see may be due to this auditory side
effect rather than direct your
modulation so that means that we really
need to look inside the brain to see
what the ultrasound is doing at the same
time our in-vitro results show that we
have robust direct excitation of the
neurons it doesn't seem to be toxic and
it involves specific molecular
mechanisms so there is also a direct
modulation that's happening and so the
next phase of our work and for others
working in this field is to figure out
what are what is the set of parameters
that we can use acoustically to minimize
the auditory side effects while
maximizing the direct neuromodulation
and hopefully we can get as much of that
separation as possible and then for
whatever remains design proper shamp
controls that would be needed to
overcome these auditory effects and we
have continuing NH brain initiative
funded project that involves several
people the investigators listed on the
slide where we're continuing to work in
transgenic mice in cultured neurons
we're doing computational modeling to
see how the ultrasound field gets
converted into other frequencies shear
waves etc to lead to potential auditory
effects and direct effects and human
psychophysical experiments to try to
document what human subjects would be
experiencing and how we can how we can
design good sham controls to make this
really useful technology so that's what
I want to say about the direct
modulation and now I want to
talk about how we can bring this to a
more kind of molecular engineered cell
type-specific level and the idea is that
you know for trying to study the
activity of specific brain regions or
we're trying to treat a disease it's
often important not only to control the
location in the brain where we're trying
to modulate something and the timing of
what we're trying to do it but also to
address specific cell types because at
any given millimeter sized volume that
we're targeting with our ultrasound
they're going to be multiple cell types
they're they're involved in different
processes and pathways and the ideal
technology for newer modulation would
allow us to non-invasively control
location timing and cell types and the
technology we're working on to allow us
to do that is something that we call
acoustically targeted chemo genetics and
unsurprisingly the location targeting
here is being done with focused
ultrasound because of the advantages
that I talked about earlier except here
instead of direct modulation at the time
of those sounds being applied the
function of the ultrasound is to locally
open the blood-brain barrier to allow
the transiently allow the entry of
nanometer sized particles into that part
of the brain and the particles were
introducing our viral vectors that enter
the brain just at that location and are
excluded elsewhere by the BBB and they
can deliver a genetic payload under cell
type-specific promoters and the genetic
payload in this case our team and
genetic receptors that can be activated
by chemo genetic ligands like the CNO
ligand that's shown here and so the idea
is that we can combine these three
things together to give us access to a
particular brain lesion specific cell
types than those region with timing that
we can control through the chemo genetic
ligand administration and I just want to
go briefly through each of these
components so first of all focused also
on blood-brain barrier opening is a
technology that's been developed over
the last 20 25 years by several groups
that has made really amazing progress
and we're following in their footsteps
and the key idea here is that normally
the BBB comprises
tight junctions that prevent most
proteins and nanoparticles entering from
circulation into the brain but in this
case we administer microbubbles
fda-approved
or some contrast agents that go through
the blood and wherever we're applying
the focused ultrasound with particular
parameters that we're using we cause
these bubbles to expand and contract and
push against the endothelial wall and
this kind of massaging action causes the
tight junctions to open just the crack
to now allow particles that are a few up
to a few tens of nanometers in size to
enter into the brain and after a few
hours these tight junctions close back
up and this is something that has been
worked on for a number of years and
actually recently was demonstrated very
elegantly in humans I'm showing some
data on the bottom right of the slide
here from the nature Communications
paper that sighted there at the bottom
where that is a human brain and the
little white area there a little white
rectangle is something that where the
older sound was used to open the
blood-brain barrier at that location and
an MRI contrast agent that's normally
BBB impermeable was able to enter and
provide that context so this is a
technique that works all the way from
small animal models to to human subjects
now the particles that we're introducing
after opening the BBB
Rav viral vectors because they're small
and you can use them to transfer
clearance people do it all the time with
intracranial injections and you can put
in your gene of interest under a cell
type specific promoter if one is
available and we'd like a V for those
considerations and also because recently
they were one of the first types of
viral vectors to be approved for gene
therapy by the FDA and the payload that
we're introducing are chemo genetic
receptors I think most of this audience
is going to be familiar with them really
a beautiful technology in which you
modify a receptor like a GPCR to stop
responding to its native
neurotransmitter and instead respond to
a designer drug and in our case we're
using this class of receptors called
dreads that was
by Brian Roth in his group that respond
to
clozapine and oxide CNO as well as other
new ligands that that people have
developed and so the idea I'm putting
this all together is that we do a brief
focused on procedure where we apply the
ultrasound to the brain region that we
want to control open the BBB inject
systemically Rav viral vectors encoding
dreads under cell type-specific promoter
let them enter the brain at that
location wait a couple weeks for
expression to take hold and subsequently
whenever we want to control that part of
the brain we just give the chemo genetic
ligand and the beauty of this from my
perspective is that we only have to do
the ultrasound watts and it's a 15
minute procedure and then from then on
you don't have to walk around with an
ultrasound transducer on your head to
achieve near modulation you just have to
take a systemically available small
molecule and conversely the small
molecule therapy works like a normal
pharmacological treatment except instead
of that small molecule acting on all
parts of the brain that may have the
receptor for it and acting in a way that
produces side-effects now this drug is
only going to be acting on the part of
the brain and only on the neurons and
and the cell types that we selected we
targeted through our ultrasound gene
delivery procedure so how well does this
work well initially we did this in mice
and we wanted to control the mouse
hippocampus one of the nice things about
focused ultrasound even compared to
intracranial injections is that to cover
a certain region you don't have to do
multiple discreet injections you can
just sweep the ultrasound beam in paint
the pattern of gene expression that you
want and so in this case we're doing
that in the mouths of the campus and we
can check immediately after the
procedure using an MRI contrast agent
where we've opened the BBB so we can see
here that we were successful in opening
it at the hippocampus and then we inject
our viral vectors in this case we have a
fluorophore
our dread receptor that we can tag and
then we can look a few weeks later where
we got our expression and you can see
here that we have nicely transfected the
important parts of the hippocampus and
we get transfection levels that are on
the order of 50 percent of cells at the
doses of virus that were administering
here and we can also make the cells that
cell type selective for example
targeting transfection to only
excitatory neurons and to show that this
works we perform the behavioral
experiments with fear conditioning in
mice where the idea was that we used
acoustically targeted Kim's genetics to
put in inhibitory dreads into excitatory
neurons in the hippocampus such that if
we administer CNO before my salmon ago
our fear conditioning we would suppress
memory formation and subsequent fear
recall in the mice that receive this you
know and not in the mice that either
didn't receive the attack treatment or
didn't receive the chemo genetic ligand
before undergoing fewer training and
indeed that turned out to be the case so
you can see in the plot on the left here
that we're able to suppress Theo recall
as measured by context freezing in the
recall task by more than a factor of two
and this magnitude of this effect is
comparable to what people have seen
previously with chemo genetic and
optogenetic treatments so in this case
we were able to implement this
technology successfully in mouse model
so the advantages from our point of view
is that this is a fully non-surgical
procedure can you apply the ultrasound
only once you can cover larger brain
regions by sweeping it around which
becomes even more important as you scale
this to larger animals as we'll talk
about in a moment this technology works
through well-established
mechanisms in the sense that the
blood-brain barrier opening has been
worked on for some time viral vectors
have been worked on for some time Hakeem
genetics has been worked on for some
time and so we're combining those
established techniques together and we
don't have to wonder
about you know how how is this all
working like we do with a direct
ultrasonic ear modulation of course the
downside is that we don't you know
control things on this kind of
millisecond or second timescale that you
could in principle do with direct
modulation but instead we're modulating
things on the time scale of the
pharmacokinetics of the chemo genetic
ligand but you know I think for a lot of
experiments and potential therapeutic
approaches that time scale is adequate
and also gives us some room to play with
because people are always developing new
chemo genetic receptors and and ligands
and so where we are with that work is
developing attack 2.0 this is an NIH
funded project from the brain initiative
that we're very excited about where we
are trying to scale this technology to
non-human primates and we think that as
a system in which this technique could
really shine because it's otherwise
difficult to deliver viral vectors into
kind of the size and distribution of
brain regions that we and others are
interested in doing in this type of
animal model now to do that we're trying
to enhance all the different aspects of
our system for example we are
engineering the viral sera types that
we're using in mice we used a benign
where we'd like to develop new serotypes
that are even better at entering the
brain at the location of ultrasonic
blood-brain barrier opening and I do
less in terms of transfecting other
parts of the body even though we're
using them under cell type-specific
promoters and this would give us a
better therapeutic window and allow us
to use a smaller dose of these viral
vectors we're testing new chemo genetic
reagents that a lot of groups have been
publishing that are very exciting and
we're going to be adapting them into
this into the system and trying to
develop inexpensive ultrasound arrays
for use in non-human primates the
devices that I showed when introducing
focused ultrasound that are used in
humans for ablation are very expensive
and probably not something that would
get disseminated widely in the
our science community but there are some
technologies that would allow us to make
that much less expensive because our
goal is to make this that's gonna be
something that's going to be useful for
non-human primate another animal model
research as broadly as possible and
doing all of these things required as a
multidisciplinary team and so we have
the list of investigators myself
Doris Sound Viviana Grandin ro at Cal
Tech who are working on the viral
engineering and implementation initial
implementation in non-human primates
Charles caskey will Grissom and lumen
Chen at Vanderbilt who are experts in
focused ultrasound and using MRI to
visualize and control that ultrasound as
well as non-human primate neuroscience
which will allow us to validate our
approach in two different labs to
different animal models to make this
really a robust technology and this is
something that this very wealthy
disciplinary project is something that
is specifically enabled by the brain
initiative and we're very grateful for
that
for that support so to summarize you
know I talked about this bottom left
quadrant here where we can use sound
waves to control neural activity and I
showed a couple of different ways of
doing that the broader statement that
I'd like to make for people that are
interested in this field is that
recently it's also becoming possible to
use ultrasound to visualize neural
activity and in technology that's
available already today you can do that
through human dynamics with functional
ultrasound develop developed by Mikhail
tantor and colleagues in Paris and we
are also developing molecular tools that
allow us to look at things like gene
expression and potentially more dynamic
signals using ultrasound instead of
light and some of the references for
that work are listed in the top left so
with that I'd like to thank my lab and
our collaborators and our supporters
especially the brain initiative you know
this kind of work takes a big team of
multidisciplinary people to pull off and
so I'm grateful for that I'm grateful to
everybody who is watching this and I
welcome questions if you'd like to do
that feel free to get in touch with me
you know thank you